and be
had.
and
directed towards
have
as of yet not completely committed
themselves.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala asks
rhetorically
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala says asks
rhetorically in this verse,
is it not about time for the believer
believers
to truly
accept
and truly find
and humility
at the remembrance of Allah and what
Allah has sent down of the truth.
Has the time not come yet?
This is an interesting and very curious
verse. Why? Because it's directed to
those who already believe.
It's not directed towards the
non-Muslims.
It's not directed towards the mushri
or the people of the book. It's directed
towards the followers of the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
and
surah had
is a chapter which was revealed in
Medina.
This is speaking to the companions of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam and
speaking to every believer or every
subsequent believer who is not yet
completely submitted and accepted.
It doesn't mean that these believers did
not completely accept the message of
Allah or the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam. If that were the
case, Allah would not begin the verse by
saying
those who believe. Has the time not come
yet? Is it not yet time for those who
believe
to have
for the remembrance of Allah and what
Allah has sent down of the truth. So
he's speaking to those who believe
but it's a belief that is not yet it's
it's a hesitant
belief.
This hesit hesitancy
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala addresses it
elsewhere and says
oh you who have believed
enter into Islam and submission to Allah
entirely.
All of you.
Every aspect of yourself. Not just some
parts. Not just your body and not your
heart. Not just your words and not your
beliefs. Not just your words and not
your actions.
Not just some of your money and the rest
of it goes elsewhere.
Has the time not come for the believers
to finally fully embrace what Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has sent down of the
truth. This is a very striking verse.
He says subhanahua
[Silence]
for for their hearts to find true
and humility before the remembrance of
Allah and what Allah has sent down.
Notice the words here. He says for their
hearts
to reach that state of their heart of
hearts, the essence of themselves, not
just their body, not just some of their
actions, but we only go so far with this
following the prophet thing saiam.
We don't want to take it to the extreme.
We don't want to be extremists in our
beliefs.
We don't want to push the envelope too
far.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam sunnah
is all-encompassing of anything and
everything that the human being could
experience in his existence. Everything.
Everything.
To the point that the companions counted
the amount of white hairs in the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam's head
to the point that the companions
watched his eyes and how they moved
to the point that they watched his mood
sai was to where it was almost like
telepathy. If he disliked something they
immediately picked up on it. They
immediately submitted.
They
completely embraced.
And a lot of times we are fooled by
time. We say, "Well, too much time has
gone by.
How am I going to change everything now?
I've already committed to whoever I am
now. I'm already 40 years old or 50
years old or 60 years old or whatever it
is. Most of the companions of the
prophet sallall.aii was believed
at at later ages. Many of them were
over the age of 40. Most of them were
over the age of 30 which at that time
was essentially
middle-aged
because of the lifespans of people at
that time. Salman
as agreed upon amongst the scholars of
Islam was over 70 years old when he
became Muslim and followed the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. over 70 years old.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala asks, "Has the
time not come for them to wake up for
them to take this seriously?"
Because what happens when we don't
commit? What does hesitation do to us?
It destroys everything. Hesitation is a
disease. Why is that? Because when you
hesitate,
you're not doing something and you're
not doing something else. You're neither
here nor there. A person hesitates
and so they miss out on the dunya
because they haven't committed to it and
they miss out on the hereafter because
they haven't committed to it. They end
up living this kind of mediocre
middle ground
which is a very depressing sight to see
the human being in because the human
being is a magnificent creature with
incredible faculties.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "Has the
time not come for them to finally
find themselves completely humble before
the remembrance of Allah and what Allah
has sent down of the truth? Has the time
not come for them not to be," he
continues, for them not to be those
who were given the book before them?
and time transpired
and their hearts grew hard over time.
The people of the book when they first
would accept and we look at for instance
a person when they have this kind of
awakening this epiphany in their life.
Most of us have had this this moment
when we realized
the
h the delicate nature of our
existence how serious things are
that life and death is not a joking
matter and so we turn to Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and our heart becomes very soft and we
try to learn and we try to observe and
we try to become become better. And then
time goes by and our hearts become hard
over time. And then when we look back,
we see that that was actually 20 years
ago. That was actually 30 years ago. And
I only had about five, six months, a
year when my heart was truly open. And
then the rest is just going through the
motions.
They lost the spirits and they
stagnated. They stopped there 20 years
ago. They didn't get better. They didn't
advance. Time went by and their hearts
became hard. The excitement is gone.
And they
relinquish themselves to the drudgery
and monotony
of mediocrity.
This is a killer.
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala said, "And
that they not be those who were
given the bat the book before them."
And so when they first received the
book, they were excited. Their hearts
were soft. They were enthusiastic.
But time went by and over time they
stagnated and the excitement went away
and they didn't work to keep that flame
alive.
And so their hearts became hard.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then gives us
hope in the next verse. He says,
[Silence]
He says in the next verse,
"And that they not be those who
were given the book before them. And
time went by and their hearts fell into
hardness.
And many of them are sinful people now.
The only thing that remains of that
excitement that they had that day is a
husk, a shell
of what was once.
He says in the next verse, "Know all of
you that Allah brings the earth back to
life after its death." You look at a
piece of land,
bitter, bitter cold of winter comes and
bites it and the land dies. And you come
upon this land, especially an area like
this. If you go somewhere up north where
there are brutal winters,
you see the earth die. Not a single
green anywhere. It's nothing but
skeletons of trees.
And then
slowly it warms up. Slowly the rain
comes. Slowly the cold recedes and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala brings life back to
that land and it is lush and green and
pollinated.
It's an it's incredible. It's a miracle.
Likewise,
Allah can bring the heart back to life
even after its death just he brings
that piece of land back to life after
its death.
But we have to try.
What happens when the heart becomes
hard? Here's what happens. Tell me if
this story sounds familiar.
A person will perhaps not really pay
much mind to religion or their
relationship with Allah. And then
something happens in their life, a
near-death experience, someone close to
them dies, an illness, something.
And they get shaken awake and suddenly
their priorities shift and now they see
that most of what humanity is is
enveloped itself in is just and a waste
of time and just busy work and that none
of it really matters
in the face of death. And so the person
turns to Allah
and now they find themselves in the
masid. Now they want to learn. Now
whenever they hear
someone say Allah said their ear perks
up. Whenever they hear someone say the
messenger of Allah said their ear perks
up and they fall still to listen to what
this is.
And during that time their heart is soft
and open and they learn
and their relationship with Allah
grows and blossoms.
But then
they reach a plateau
and the fear recedes
and things settle back into normaly.
And so they're still going through the
motions that they learned,
but they're not as enthusiastic anymore.
And slowly over time as shan
brings them one step at a time, one
thing at a time, one decision at a time
until the only thing that is left
is the outward appearance. They still
have the thobon. They still have the
beard. They still have the lingo, right?
They still talk. And they still know the
the narrations in the verses, right? And
they still know this is correct and this
is incorrect and this is but
it's not really as serious anymore. And
if I change the way I am now, you know,
I'm already worked into a habit. So
you'll find the person they go to the
masid out of habit inertia
but the heart is now hard the heart is
near dead this verse here
one of the greatest scholars in the
history of Islam
he was a contemporary and appear of
Malik Annis the
Him and Malik, Im Malik, they were
peers. They sought knowledge together.
Only Alm Malik was more social than he
was. And so he receded after
after becoming a scholar. He receded and
focused on worship in his home. and he
disliked notoriety. Whereas Imam Malik,
he was more social and he became a
public figure and had many students. But
he is if not more knowledgeable
than I Malik, he's no less knowledgeable
than I Malik.
Many of us haven't even heard of him
because of this. His name is
was abandoned.
That was his that was his his thing
all through his youth growing up. He was
abandoned.
Meaning that they would wait in the
shadows of paths on the outskirts of
cities. People would come by, they would
rob them. not at gunpoint at that time
at sword point, right?
And so people feared,
everyone knew.
They didn't know him as a scholar. Quite
the opposite. They knew him as a
ruthless bandit.
Kill a man over pennies.
and he had a relationship with a young
girl that he was on his way to see one
day. And he was jumping over a fence to
go see his
his f his his love interest. And as
he was jumping over this fence, he heard
someone know someone praying at night in
his house reciding
[Silence]
And for some reason at that moment this
verse pierced his heart
and he said, "Yes, oh Allah, the time
has come." And so he retreated. He
retreated to an old abandoned shack that
he found at night because it was a
stormy night and he found a group of
Muslims there that didn't see him.
They were shacked up there too and they
were discussing with each other should
we go now try to go home now or wait
till morning and one of them said now if
we go now we have a very good chance of
popping out at us and robbing us let's
stay here for the night he overheard
them
and he said to himself
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has brought me
here to hear with my known years what I
have done to the Muslim
and so he turned to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and he became
one of the sharpest minds in the history
of Islam
and there's lots of stories that
one of them is alabi
alabi
many of us have never heard of Abdullahb
he was a drunkard.
A drunkard.
He liked to drink a nab in Iraq.
It's something that is made from
fermented dates.
And
alabi is the most prominent
student of Alam Malik. Most of the
narrations that Bkari Muslim narrate
from Imam Malik they took from Alani. So
he is the of Bkari Muslim. Alanabi
what's the origin of his story?
He was in Iraq and he saw he was with
his friends and they were known as a
nuisance. They were always drinking and
sitting in the in the path and causing
trouble with people.
and he saw this huge crowd of people, a
sea of people walking with this man who
was riding on a donkey. And he was the
only one riding and this sea of people
all around him.
And he's thinking, who is this guy? He's
riding a donkey. So he's not royalty,
but all these people.
I wonder what the big fuss is about. So
he made his way through the crowd and he
took the reigns of the donkey. Very
arrogant, very rude.
And he said, "Who are you?"
And so the people said this is
this is
referred to as
he is referred to as the most memorized
scholar of hadith in the history of
Islam.
There are less than 50 people in the
history of hadith who have ever earned
this title. Far less than that. You
could probably count them on both your
hands.
And so he said, "Who's who's
who is that? Who's
he said? They said Muhamad."
He was a scholar of hadith. a muhadith.
He said, "Oh, being that you're a
muhadith, tell me a hadith,
you know, he's some kind of gesture
in a court. Dance for me. Come on, front
of all these people." How rude, how
arrogant he was behaving. Oh, you're a
muadi. Tell me a hadith. Let me hear.
And it was actually him leaving
this place in Iraq and he was going
for traveling and all these people were
escorting him to the gates of the
city
because the muadith he used to travel
and gather hadith. And so
he narrated a hadith to him.
He said and the hadith is on the
authority of
who said that the messenger of Allah
said
the narration he chose for him was that
the prophet said if you have no shame
then do whatever you want as the
narration. What's he saying?
you have no shame. This is why you're
doing what you're doing. This is why
you're behaving this.
And it was a hammer in his head.
And he went back and sobered up and
asked about the most knowledgeable man
on earth. And so he was directed to
Malik Annis in Medina. He left and
stayed with Malik Annis until he died.
memorized every narration that Malik
Annis had to offer.
Now he knows
who Sha is.
So now he wants to go back to Iraq to
meet him again to narrate narrations
directly from Sha because now he's
taking narrations from Malik who took
them from Sha. He wants to take them
directly from Sha. He went back to Iraq
and found that Sha had already passed
away.
And so that's the only narration we have
from
many stories.
one of the seven reciters of the Quran.
He has a recitation himself and he is
the sole founder of the Kufi school of
thought in the science of an as a matter
of fact
himself im himself said if you want to
learn Arabic
take it from
Alisi
never studied for the first 40 years of
his life 40 years
he was a shepherd. He was a shepherd
with his flock and he doesn't have any,
you know, anything to do with studying
or memorizing or learning or anything
that. And one day he was with his
flock and he came by a woman
who was talking to her son and her son
was outside of their little hut or their
little house. And she was fighting with
her son, telling her son. And he was
walking by, fighting with her son, go to
the
is the place where you go to memorize
the Quran as a kid. Go and take your
lessons and memorize the Quran so you
can be somebody. Do you want to end up
him?
She pointed to
just walking by. He got caught by a
stray bullet there.
Just walking by. You want to end up like
him? Look at him. Go learn the Quran.
40 years old thought to himself, "My
goodness,
I have now become
a a an analogy of ignorance at 40 years
old.
Something shameful."
And so he went and he started to study.
He has his own recitation. Seven
recitations of the Quran. One of them
are from Alisi.
Number two, Elisi founded the whole
school of thought of the
Kufi Med.
He there are only two schools of thought
in
Kufi. He is the leader of the Kufi and
the founder
and Alisi was so pronounced so renowned
and esteemed
that a im himself
would tell his students if you want to
learn true Arabic you go to Alis who was
alis nobody he was that guy that's where
he started but how do these things
happen they happen when a person takes
it seriously iously and submit
seriously. But this kind of hesitating
and halfstepping and I'm not sure and
what will my wife think and what's my
dad going to think? What will my
co-workers think? I don't, you know, I
don't want to be too religious. You
don't want to be too, you know, Muslim.
We just want just a certain level of
Islam, but not too far the ones you
see in the movies, right?
You have a Spider-Man movie or you have
a Hollywood movie and you have one
Muslim girl in there thrown in there
just to show us that hey, you know,
we're all together. She has her hijab
on. Not too Muslim. We don't we don't
want very much Islam. Just just a just a
dash of Islam. Not enough to really
affect your civ your civic life. Right?
This is one choice. Another choice is
enter into Islam entirely.
[Silence]
All subhanahu
alhamdulillah